Diese Untertitel
sind live produziert.
sub1
Stimmen für spätere Lockerung:
sub2
Immer mehr Politiker
sprechen sich dafür aus,
sub3
die Corona-Beschränkungen bis
in den Dezember hinein zu verlängern.
sub4
Mission "Mitregieren":
sub5
Die Grünen beschließen
ein neues Grundsatzprogramm
sub6
und wollen mehr Bürgerbeteiligung.
sub7
Deutscher Doppelerfolg:
sub8
Gleich zum Saisonbeginn
gewinnt Markus Eisenbichler
sub9
den Skisprung-Weltcup in Polen,
Zweiter wird Karl Geiger.
sub10
Guten Abend und willkommen.
sub11
An meiner Seite ist Rudi Cerne
für den Sport.
sub12
Auf welche Einschränkungen müssen
wir uns bis Weihnachten einstellen?
sub13
Darüber entscheiden am Mittwoch
Bund und Länder.
sub14
Schon jetzt fordern einige,
sub15
die Corona-Maßnahmen zu verlängern
oder sogar zu verschärfen,
sub16
denn noch zeigen die seit drei Wochen
geltenden Einschränkungen
sub17
nicht die erhoffte Wirkung.
sub18
David Sauer berichtet.
sub19
Protest gegen die Corona-Politik,
wie hier in Berlin heute
sub20
auch in einigen anderen Städten.
sub21
Doch ihre Forderung nach
einem baldigen Ende der Maßnahmen
sub22
wird sich wohl nicht erfüllen.
sub23
Eher ist eine Verlängerung
des Teil-Shutdowns wahrscheinlich,
sub24
beim nächsten Bund-Länder-Treffen
am Mittwoch.
sub25
Jedenfalls haben weder
Sozialdemokraten noch Union derzeit
sub26
eine gangbare Alternative
anzubieten.
sub27
Die Zahlen sind
einfach viel zu hoch.
sub28
Die Krankenhäuser laufen voll
und die Todeszahlen steigen.
sub29
Und insofern ist klar:
sub30
Es gibt keinen Anlass
zu einer Entwarnung.
sub31
Wir müssen uns
damit vertraut machen,
sub32
dass der Lockdown verlängert wird.
sub33
Nachholbedarf sieht
auch die Bundeskanzlerin,
sub34
bittet aber um Geduld bis Mittwoch.
sub35
Dem kann und will ich
nicht vorgreifen.
sub36
Die Bürger*innen sollen
eine geschlossene Antwort bekommen
sub37
von Bund und Ländern.
sub38
Darauf haben sie ein Recht,
daran arbeiten wir.
sub39
Derzeit infizieren sich
je 100.000 Einwohner
sub40
in sieben Tagen bundesweit 139 -
Ziel sind weniger als 50.
sub41
Liegt der Wert höher,
sagen Experten,
sub42
überlastet langfristig
das Gesundheitssystem.
sub43
Viele haben schon den Advent
im Blick, fragen sich,
sub44
wie in einem Monat
das Weihnachtsfest
sub45
unter Corona-Bedingungen
aussehen soll.
sub46
Die kalte Jahreszeit ist dann
aber noch lange nicht vorbei.
sub47
Deshalb brauche es eine Strategie
für den ganzen Winter,
sub48
fordert etwa die Ministerpräsidentin
von Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
sub49
Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall
eine Langfristperspektive.
sub50
Wir müssen der Bevölkerung sagen,
wie wir durch den Winter kommen.
sub51
Es ist wichtig,
sub52
dass wir weiter Schutzmaßnahmen
haben im Dezember und Januar.
sub53
Der "Schweigemarsch" in Berlin war
am Ende ganz und gar nicht still.
sub54
Gegendemonstranten
machten jede Menge Lärm,
sub55
aber alles blieb
friedlich und geordnet.
sub56
Angemeldet waren 5.000 Personen,
rund 1.000 zählte die Polizei.
sub57
Weil nicht alle Gesundheitsämter
am Wochenende Daten übermitteln,
sub58
sind die Corona-Zahlen sonntags
in der Regel etwas niedriger.
sub59
So auch heute:
Laut Robert Koch-Institut
sub60
gab es binnen 24 Stunden
15.741 Neuinfektionen.
sub61
Das sind 1.206 weniger
als vergangenen Sonntag.
sub62
Die Zahl der Todesfälle im Zusammen-
hang mit dem Virus stieg um 138.
sub63
Wie groß ist die Corona-Gefahr
in Bus und Bahn?
sub64
In unserer ZDFheute-App zeigen wir,
welche Faktoren eine Rollen spielen
sub65
und warum Politiker und
Wissenschaftler dazu aufrufen,
sub66
öffentliche Verkehrsmittel,
wenn möglich, zu meiden.
sub67
Finanzminister Scholz
will für das kommende Jahr
sub68
offenbar deutlich mehr Schulden
aufnehmen als bisher bekannt:
sub69
statt 96 Mrd.
mindestens 160 Mrd.,
sub70
berichten verschiedene Medien.
sub71
Scholz selbst sagt aber, für
die Jahre 2020/21 zusammengenommen
sub72
werde der Korridor
"ungefähr der gleiche" bleiben.
sub73
Am Donnerstag will
der Haushaltsausschuss
sub74
weiter über den Haushalt 2021
beraten.
sub75
Die Grünen wollen in die Regierung.
sub76
Das wurde bei ihrem virtuellen
Parteitag deutlicher denn je.
sub77
Nach 18 Jahren
sub78
haben sie zudem ein neues
Grundsatzprogramm verabschiedet.
sub79
Das soll noch mehr
Wähler*innen ansprechen.
sub80
Die drei großen Streitthemen dabei:
sub81
Klimawandel, Volksentscheide,
innere Sicherheit.
sub82
Andreas Huppert und
Lars Bohnsack berichten.
sub83
Abschluss eines historischen
Grünen-Parteitags,
sub84
dem ersten digitalen.
sub85
Ein neues Grundsatzprogramm
ist beschlossen.
sub86
Leitlinien, gemacht
nicht nur für Mitglieder,
sub87
sondern mit dem Anspruch
auf Umsetzung.
sub88
Das nächste Jahrzehnt
wird entscheidend sein.
sub89
Sei es beim Klimaschutz,
sub90
sei es für den sozialen Zusammenhalt
in unserem Land.
sub91
Jetzt, in einer Pandemie,
wo sich Dinge neu sortieren,
sub92
haben wir die Grundlage dafür
geschaffen, Dinge anders,
sub93
und zwar besser zu machen.
sub94
Die Themen breit -
Grundsatzprogramm eben.
sub95
Natürlich mit "Klimaschutz",
dazu "Innere Sicherheit",
sub96
"Gen-Technik", bis hin zum heutigen
Streitthema: "Direkte Demokratie".
sub97
Viele aus der Partei wollen
Volksabstimmungen auf Bundesebene.
sub98
Ich plädiere dafür,
sub99
die Angst vor dem Wunsch
des Mitmachens und Mitbestimmens
sub100
der Menschen abzulegen.
sub101
Die Parteispitze um Robert Habeck
sub102
will Bürgerräte
statt Volkabstimmungen.
sub103
Dabei sollen per Los
ausgewählte Bürger
sub104
an Gesetzen mitarbeiten dürfen.
sub105
Volksentscheide werden polarisieren.
sub106
Es sind Ja-Nein-Entscheidungen,
es ist Schwarz oder Weiß.
sub107
Sie werden nicht den Diskurs
der Gesellschaft befördern,
sub108
sondern die Spaltung.
sub109
Am Ende heißt es:
keine Volksabstimmungen.
sub110
Und auch bei der Absenkung
des Wahlalters,
sub111
auf 16 Jahre statt auf 14,
setzt sich der Vorstand durch.
sub112
Jede Zeit hat ihre Farbe,
so der Parteitagsslogan.
sub113
Demonstrativ geschlossen
und mit dem Willen zu regieren
sub114
ziehen die Grünen
ins kommende Wahljahr.
sub115
Seit 15 Wochen gibt es in Belarus
trotz Polzeigewalt jeden Sonntag
sub116
Proteste gegen Machthaber Lukaschenko
- auch heute wieder.
sub117
In der Hauptstadt Minsk
sub118
versammelten sich die Menschen
in ihren Wohnvierteln,
sub119
da weite Teile der Innenstadt
mit Metallgittern abgesperrt waren.
sub120
Hundertschaften von Polizei und Armee
setzten Blendgranaten ein
sub121
und nahmen laut einer
Menschenrechtsorganisation
sub122
mehr als 200 Demonstranten fest.
sub123
Erst die Corona-Pandemie
in den Griff kriegen
sub124
und dann der globalen Wirtschaft
wieder auf die Sprünge helfen.
sub125
Das hat sich, grob gesagt, die G20,
sub126
also die Gruppe der
großen Industrienationen,
sub127
zum Abschluss ihres virtuellen
Gipfels vorgenommen.
sub128
Aber auch der Klimawandel
treibt sie um.
sub129
Anne Gellinek berichtet.
sub130
Kein Damen- oder Kulturprogramm,
sub131
kein Austausch
von Regierungschef*innen am Rande -
sub132
dieser von Saudi-Arabien
organisierte Videogipfel
sub133
war anders als alle zuvor.
sub134
Der Kampf gegen die Corona-Pandemie
hat das Treffen überschattet.
sub135
Die G20-Teilnehmer
sub136
wollen für eine gerechte Verteilung
von Impfstoffen sorgen,
sub137
doch fehlt es noch an Geld,
die Beschlüsse bleiben vage.
sub138
Glücklicherweise gibt es jetzt
Hoffnung auf Impfstoffe.
sub139
Und insofern stellt sich
die Frage auch sehr konkret,
sub140
dass wir nicht nur in Europa
uns Impfstoffe sichern,
sub141
so wie es
die Europäische Kommission tut,
sub142
sondern dass dies auch
für die Länder der Welt wichtig ist.
sub143
Grundsätzlich haben sich
auch alle im G20-Club
sub144
dem Klimaschutz verpflichtet,
doch sobald es konkret wird,
sub145
steht es weiterhin 19:1.
sub146
Donald Trump nutzt
seine Videobotschaft,
sub147
um das Pariser Klimaabkommen
scharf zu kritisieren.
sub148
Ein sehr unfaires Abkommen
für die Vereinigten Staaten.
sub149
Der Pariser Pakt wurde nicht
entworfen, um das Klima zu retten,
sub150
sondern um die amerikanische
Wirtschaft zu erledigen.
sub151
Die USA hätten mehr
für den Klimaschutz getan
sub152
als alle anderen Nationen, so Trump.
sub153
Ein Teilnehmer hat auch
noch mal die Gelegenheit genommen,
sub154
seine eigene Großartigkeit
zu schildern.
sub155
Es klingt nicht so, als ob Europa
Trump schwer vermissen würde.
sub156
Der nächste G20-Gipfel findet
im Oktober in Italien statt.
sub157
Dann mit den neu gewählten
US-Präsidenten: Joe Biden.
sub158
In Guatemala haben Demonstrierende
das Parlament gestürmt
sub159
und in Brand gesetzt.
sub160
Sie protestierten damit
sub161
gegen den zuvor verabschiedeten
Staatshaushalt.
sub162
Mehrere Menschen
erlitten Rauchvergiftungen.
sub163
Zuvor waren Hunderte vor den Kongress
in Guatemala-Stadt gezogen.
sub164
Sie forderten den Staatschef auf,
zurückzutreten.
sub165
Seine Partei hatte den
Milliardenhaushalt mitbeschlossen,
sub166
inklusive neuer Schulden und weniger
Geld für Bildung und Soziales.
sub167
Erfreuliches kommt
von den Skispringern.
sub168
Die haben einen Traumstart
in die Saison hingelegt.
sub169
Nach Platz zwei im
Mannschaftswettbewerb gestern
sub170
hat Markus Eisenbichler heute den
Weltcup im polnischen Wisla gewonnen,
sub171
und zwar vor seinem Teamkollegen
Karl Geiger.
sub172
* Schrei *
sub173
Ein bayerischer Urschrei als erster
Ausdruck der großen Freude.
sub174
Für Markus Eisenbichler ist es der
perfekte Start in die neue Saison.
sub175
Als Drittletzter geht er im Finale
in die Spur,
sub176
voller Selbstvertrauen nach der
erfolgreichen Sommervorbereitung.
sub177
Nach 137,5 m im ersten Durchgang
reichen dann 134 zum Sieg.
sub178
Auch, weil er bei der Landung hier
sub179
den Griff in den Schnee
knapp vermeiden kann.
sub180
Begeisterung bei Bundestrainer
Stefan Horngacher.
sub181
Denn auch der beste Deutsche
des letzten Winters, Karl Geiger,
sub182
ist schon in Topform.
sub183
Er wird Zweiter vor dem Österreicher
Daniel Huber.
sub184
Viel besser hätte die neue Saison
für die deutschen Skispringer
sub185
nicht anfangen können.
sub186
Bob-Pilot Francesco Friedrich
sub187
ist auch zu Beginn der neuen Saison
in der Erfolgsspur.
sub188
In Sigulda gewann er, wie gestern,
den Wettbewerb im Zweierbob.
sub189
Jubel bei Bob-Pilot
Francesco Friedrich
sub190
über den 38. Weltcup-Sieg
seiner Karriere.
sub191
Gemeinsam mit Anschieber
Alexander Schüller
sub192
dominiert der Deutsche
sub193
auch am zweiten Tag des Weltcup-
Auftakts im Eiskanal von Sigulda.
sub194
Bestzeit in beiden Läufen und wie
schon gestern der Sieg in Lettland.
sub195
Bundestrainer Rene Spieß
sub196
kann erneut ein bärenstarkes
Mannschaftsergebnis bejubeln.
sub197
Johannes Lochner fährt gemeinsam
mit Anschieber Eric Franke
sub198
mit zwei Zehntelsekunden Rückstand
auf Platz 2.
sub199
Als drittes deutsches Duo
sub200
landen Christoph Hafer
und Issam Ammour auf Rang 4,
sub201
hinter dem stärksten Schweizer Bob,
gelenkt von Michael Vogt.
sub202
Und in der Fußball-Bundesliga
sub203
hat Mainz mit 3:1 in Freiburg
gewonnen
sub204
und damit den ersten
Saisonsieg gefeiert.
sub205
Wettermäßig beginnt
die neue Woche unterschiedlich:
sub206
Im Norden und am Alpenrand
länger freundlich,
sub207
sonst wechselnd oder stark bewölkt
und etwas Regen,
sub208
an den Küsten einzelne Schauer.
sub209
Um 21.45 Uhr begrüßt Sie
Christian Sievers im heute journal.
sub210
Wir danken für Ihr Interesse,
sub211
wünschen Ihnen noch
einen unbeschwerten Sonntag
sub212
und empfehlen jetzt "Berlin direkt"
mit Shakuntala Banerjee.